de kiev les combats continuent l'armée
russe se targue d'avoir détruit hier
soir la plus grande réserve de carburant
de l'armée ukrainienne près de kiev le
ministère ukrainien des situations
d'urgences confirma bombardements sur la
réserve de carburant de caligny fca qui
se situe à à 40 km au sud ouest de la
capitale mais il ne donne pas de détails
sur l'importance de ce site on va
retrouver tout de suite notre envoyé
spécial à kiev gulliver craag bonjour
gulliver vous êtes actuellement dans la
capitale ukrainienne si je me trompe pas
quelle est la situation actuellement est
ce que les bombardements autour de la
capitale continue ou on assiste un peu à
une accalmie
autour de la capitale les combats
continuent c'est plutôt au nord-ouest de
la capitale autour des irp in mais aussi
des localités un peu plus loin de kiev
vers l'ouest et le sud-ouest qui ont été
la scène de combat hier et aujourd'hui
là en ce moment même je suis venu à
polignac i qui est un quartier de l'est
de kiev de rive gauche du fleuve dniepr
c'est un quartier qui a été touché les
premiers jours de l'invasion lorsque les
systèmes de défense antiaériens
ukrainiens ont abattu une requête qui
est abattue sur un immeuble près d'ici
j'ai pu constater les dégâts et aussi le
fait que beaucoup d'immeubles autour en
vue des fenêtres cassées à cause de ces
l'impact de cette explosion mais depuis
ce quartier n'a pas été touché et est en
réalité par rapport au centre ville on
constate ici qu'il y à beaucoup plus de
vies et en fin de compte c'est logique
dans le centre ville moins de monde
habite et les gens qui habitent vraiment
dans le centre ville c'est les gens plus
aisés qui ont les moyens qu'ils ont eu
les moyens de partir qu'ils ont d'autres
options dont les quartiers dortoirs
comme ici il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont
décidé de ne pas partir ou bien qui sont
parti puis revenu quand ils sont compris
que c'est relativement tranquilles dans
leur quartier et donc il est appelé le
monde dans la rue et un ambiance un peu
plus vivant je suis venu ici en réalité
pour parler de quelqu'un que je connais
de marioupol qui a quitté marioupol en
2014 déjà quand on pensait que cette
ville pourrait être attaqué par les
russes tout moment à l'autre donc il vit
maintenant à kiev mais il a des membres
de sa famille à marioupol dont il n'a
pas de nouvelles depuis des jours
d'autres amis qui sont de la ville qui
donnent des nouvelles il dit qu'ils sont
dans un état psychologique extrêmement
grave ils sont vraiment traumatisé on
voit que même quelqu'un qui habite à
kiev et qui a des amis et de la famille
à marioupol est très très traumatisée
par la destruction de cette ville est
tout de même ce que ce qui est peut-être
frappant c'est que il n'a pas hésité une
seule seconde quand je lui ai demandé
est peut-être que ça aurait été mieux de
juste rendre marioupol pour éviter cette
totale destruction et il a tout de suite
dit non non non le cren a fait la bonne
chose est la seule chose à faire parce
que si on leur avait lâché marioupol
alors il serait venu a commencé à
bombarder intensément une autre ville
par exemple pour yahoo active archive
qui a été bombardé certes mais pas du
tout avec la même intensité que
marioupol merci beaucoup gulliver craag
envoyé spécialà à kiev merci à vous